foreign
[Music]
so to jump right into things I'm going
to ask a few questions and then if it
applies to you we're going to clap twice
um so clap twice if you've ever written
a shiny app
sweet awesome that's a lot of you good
all right
um clap twice if you remember all of
your app's features
okay
and then
clap twice if you'd feel comfortable
having a co-worker rewrite part of your
app
still not a lot of you
um but most of us feel about our apps
it's our precious and we don't want
anyone else to touch it
um so this gives a bit like as sadika
was saying with automated testing as
well and having other working with team
members this brings a big motivation to
have something with automated testing so
that we don't lose our app features or
we could have a co-worker work on a new
feature and not have it destroy your
existing features
and so we'll get into this uh throughout
today
all right so to make sure everyone's on
the same page even though there's a lot
of clap
um what is shiny
so
shiny allows you to quickly build full
stack interactive web applications and
um it does this in like very few lines I
believe here to do this in other
languages it would take a lot of work
and it does this by executing reactive
Expressions uh within the server and
server like when you change one of these
reactive values
um all Downstream reactives uh must be
re like they're invalidated and then
they must be recalculated and this is
kind of you know how we can do a lot of
our reactivity within Chinese
and as sadika said there's this very
familiar workflow within shiny and
it's where we're going to tweak some of
the apps we're going to add and adjust
some of that reactivity
we'll then click run app and then this
is why we love r that we manually look
at it we can manually iterate on this
and we can do this every like 30 seconds
10 seconds even if you're really quick
and that's why we love R it's like
JavaScript it might be 10 hours if you
want to add a new feature you know with
r if you know the commands it could just
be a few seconds and that's great
but but if you have like 20 amps what if
you have many team members what if you
have things where like you know you
can't quite keep it all in your head at
once
and with manually experimenting things
are Lost in Translation
can you explain to your co-worker all of
your features and have them make sure
they manually test it properly like I
don't believe I could do that and I'm
like very familiar with infrastructure
and so it kind of crumbles once you
start doing more than just toy
application
and Kimberly says there's no chance
so this kind of opens the door to a
different package and this is the test
that package
to test that package is typically more
from the package development world of
and it performs unit testing for r
and this is where it executes formal
unit tests such as expect equal or
effect greater than
and I think this is great you can build
your whole test suite and then build out
your functionality uh try to pass that
test Suite I remember having many
situations where we might try to build
out 100 tests and let's build those
methods try to pack those tests test
driven development
and its tools are four main goals uh
number one that have fewer bugs you're
constantly testing things then things
get broken less often because you're
very aware of what's going on
you can also have more robust code
because maybe you're testing for chicken
fingers
that's not something that would
automatically test by default during my
manual
if you have better code structure
because you're breaking your your
functions down if you test each Lego
piece of your code then when you put all
that together you can believe that you
have a strong code structure at the end
very robust because you know each
component is doing very well
and then finally you have call to action
uh right now I you know getting very a
little sleep I have a new baby boy and
it's wonderful having call to action
because oh thank you uh
it's like you can set in a broken test
and say like pick this in the morning
and then you don't need that 45 minutes
to kind of warm up for the day you can
kind of jump back in be had that test
while you were deep into your coding
session
so let's take a look at uh test that and
kind of see what an example is I talked
about those formal tests this would be
like expect equal where we can do our
you know standard basic test two times
two does it equal four yes great a kind
of a non-standard one make it a little
bit more robust two times n a uh that's
n a integer you do n a regular that's
actually a logical and it would fail
um without the underscore any integer
and then new to test that edition three
is Snapshot testing snapshot testing is
where we don't do an expect equal x to Y
we say kind of keep track of this file
and then you know just make sure it
doesn't change because that file may
contain uh lots of content that can't be
put in code
so we can make an example file and then
we can say expect snapshot file from
testdot and it will compare to say it
did the file change from each run yes or
no and if it didn't then the test pack
uh so if we run uh devtools test within
the IDE you can see that those three
tests passed very quickly and you get a
success and test that does a wonderful
job of encouragement but that was a
badass code
you test over and over again get a new
random message
so I'd like to take these two worlds and
combine them into one
and here's where we'll get Chinese too
[Applause]
the shiny Test 2 is unit testing for
shiny applications but I actually want
to adjust that a little bit because it's
very difficult to write all of the unit
tests and then fill in the log instead
it's more regression testing or shiny
application
in that you have existing app behavior
and you've seen this through your own
manual testing
and you don't want to lose this
typically we do something like three
hours of work and I want to make sure
that you don't lose that three hours of
work so we're going to insert a test and
make sure that behavior does not regret
or does not go away
it executes within test stat so there's
a framework that we're all hopefully
very familiar with and it should be very
natural as to what happened
and any tests the uh extra helper
methods exist within there they all
leverage test that expect snapshot file
so there's nothing special that tinytest
is doing it's just kind of orcharding
everything into a nice place pack
and then especially important it's built
on remote which uses your local
chromium-based browser typically Chrome
and uh allows you to execute headless
browser test so it doesn't need to open
up it can execute just as like GitHub
action or even hidden in your terminal
but one of the Beautiful Things is that
you can view that live test application
I'll show a demo of that later
and then also because it's Chrome you
can have your familiar debugging tools
that Chrome provides and those are very
very powerful
so elephants in the room uh what about
tiny test
um shiny test if you are familiar with
it it's entering maintenance mode uh the
Headless browser has been uh set on end
of life for a few years now it
Phantom JS is not really usable I
actually would argue it is worse than IE
and ie has already been killed by
Microsoft
um and also Chinese moving towards
wanting to have everyone use bootstrap 5
and it is not bootstrap 5 compatible so
it is impossible to do these tests uh
Okay so
shiny test two
um also it has a different headless
browser so all of your prior screenshots
if you had them they would be a failure
and that's not something that I wanted
to introduce on everyone
also because of test that we have a
different file structure and um since we
had the opportunity we also streamlined
the API to leverage test that as well as
a different R API as well that's why
there's two different
so before we get into some uh deeper
code let's look at a very uh small toy
example shiny uh app and what it's going
to do it's going to ask your name we're
then going to greet that name and then
we should have a
or a reading
so I'll insert my name Barrett I'm gonna
click create I'll say hello Barrett
that's it great Play app very
complicated I know uh but it's nice
because we have a text input we have an
action button and we also have a text
out these are very common components
within your shiny application and they
may be uh in located in very different
locations but
um like these are a good example of what
happened
if I was to uh set that up as a tech we
would need to set up our own test that
code so we would say test that the app
says hello Barrett and this is in the
file there
if we were to insert some shiny Test 2
code you don't need to know it exactly
but we can kind of walk through it
we're here inside the test we will set
up our app driver this is the thing that
kind of creates everything gets promote
going get your shiny app going and then
it handles all the interactions
and then we tell the app hey set the
input and the name is Barrett
then when that's all done
click the Greet button and then when
everything has been uh done as well say
expect values because I want to make
sure my input and outputs are just
and I think it's just so beautiful that
in four lines of code I set up the app
set some input and make expectations and
it's not a crazy thing
so let's run that test because we want
to run these tests over and over and
rapidly constantly
in real time took a few seconds not too
bad now your three hours of work that
you've kind of worked on is now captured
in being able to replay in a few seconds
make sure that that work is never bought
but writing test is hard does everyone
but Hadley
um
the good news is is there's a method
called record and I think this is great
because you don't need to write those
tests itself we can capture all of the
shiny interactions and then record that
as a test that test
and I really want to stress this because
I love the the McDonald's boat of if you
have time to lean you have time to clean
but in this case if you have time to
rest you have time to record it
and this is because recording these
tests is not that long when you do your
manual testing it takes just a few
seconds 10 seconds this whole gift here
is just 10 seconds it's a very familiar
greeting we do the interactions and then
I click expect values and I save and
that's it
so 10 seconds for me to go in
do the manual manipulations that I want
I then save my shiny values or expect my
shiny values
and I think it's just great and your all
of your app will live on the side and
you can see your code update as to
what's being generated and then when
we're all done after next at least one
expectation made then we
great
that code that was recorded this is
actually what is stored um so I didn't
doctor this one um and it is oddly
similar to the one that we looked at
before just the only difference is the
test game is just saying that it's a
report
let's look at that testing we want I
want to still then always run your Dev
tools run these faster like constantly
because they are fast and quick not too
bad I want to make sure that you don't
lose any
but remember earlier I was talking about
how we had to promote
and promote you can view your headless
browser if you're familiar with shiny
test it was a black box you could only
poke it from the outside and pray there
is not much you could do
um with our app they are getting more
and more complicated and that's awesome
like it's wonderful
but if at the Headless browser it means
you can't see it like our regular
browser say but promote allows you to
view it so there's a method you can run
interactively called half dollar or
dollar View
and
uh this is what it will so this in this
gif have the code the test on the right
that I'm running interactively in my
console
and what we'll do is we will Library
shiny Test 2 I will then run my app
driver working directory app call app
View
and this will open up Chrome browser on
your location you can see the app there
and you can on the right side you can
also see all of your familiar Chrome
debugging tools which is great you can
also see your console at the bottom a
tiny test I'll kind of spit out some
information what's happening at least my
knowledge if I call set input you can
see the app update live it didn't have
to do anything you didn't have to
refresh when we when we clicked read it
actually updated live you can see the
output there
I think that is just so powerful because
you can be like why is this test not
working run run run run insert a half
dollar view in the console then you see
exactly where it's at and you know your
app and you'll be able to discover what
wrong whereas shiny test two can only
tell you what
so I have some suggestions as you leave
the shiny Shire and your way
um
number one is to use shiny export test
values
this is a method that I was actually
unaware of I'm on the shiny theme and I
really want to give it more Limelight
because uh it is very powerful we don't
need to test just input and output
there's actually a third group called
export
and you can export react values you can
export your reactive value and it
doesn't need to be an input or something
that has been rendered as an output this
is great because testing mode can will
allow for this to work and you can
expose more information and more work
logic that doesn't in your normal app
that you use day to day
also try to limit objects under your own
control
um if you do something like a data
structure and then you send it into DT
in DT updates because it needs to like
nothing wrong with DT doing that but
your output might change which would
produce false positive so maybe just
test your your data frame going in and
then just trust that DT will always run
another one is again if you use expect
snapshot file
um be careful about what's going on with
those uh snapshots all the snapshot does
it says I agree with myself but it
doesn't mean that it's Direct
so you need to at least manually confirm
that that snapshot is correct and then
if you do agree with yourself you are
correct so that's good but there's that
little logical loophole
um be safe you can always use uh manual
expectations or explicit expectations
such as expect equal because that will
always be truthful comparing it to a
static
and then lastly minimize the number of
screenshots
um expectations
screenshots are worth a thousand tests
um they do test everything but you can
also Imagine that's a very high false
positive rate
um with a thousand tests and so they're
very brittle they're open to a lot of uh
issues and you cannot also you cannot
compare across operating systems or R
versions so it gets um very unwieldy
very quickly
um so unless screenshots are absolutely
there I would argue maybe not do that
so recap any test do
um regression testing for your app you
want to keep that behavior over time
if you have time to rest you have time
to record a test
and then interactively view your
application whenever possible if you run
into trouble
and hopefully Gandalf will change this
tune from you shall not pass
two
thank you
[Music]